joining me now is Carrie Lake Republican
nominee for Arizona governor Kerry first
of all you know I you know everyone
knows that I was I wasn't you know on
your bandwagon during the primary for
sure but I'm watching you
take on the media and the only other
person who's done it like you is
DeSantis and Trump that's it I mean of
everyone I've seen out there what put
the fight in your belly to do what
you're doing today given all these
headlines
oh my gosh thank you for having me on
I'm so glad that you're um that you're
having me on I appreciate it so much
Laura I'll tell you I worked on the
inside of the media for nearly 30 years
so I understand as they say how the
sausage is made and I've turned the
tables on them every event we go to we
draw massive a media crowd and we are
always reporting and recording them and
we show the people what the media is up
to because usually they ask the nasty
question that's full of an agenda and
narrative and then they cut that part
out and never show the people how bad
they appear so we're just actually
flipping the tables on them and and
revealing who they really are
now Carrie I want to play um your
opponent uh Katie Hobbs latest rationale
for dodging you watch
for me this debate about debates is over
Kerry lake is so desperate for a debate
because she is scared to sit down and
have an in-depth conversation because it
will highlight her level of inexperience
the lack of qualification to be governor
Carrie it's your inexperience and lack
of qualification that makes you want to
debate that kind of doesn't make sense
but your reaction yeah they said the
same thing about Ronald Reagan they said
he's just an actor he just reads scripts
he used to be a Democrat what does he
know and he went on to be truly probably
the greatest governor of this country
ever saw when he was governor of
California and turned that state around
and boy do we need another Ronald Reagan
in California right now so I don't uh
you know nobody's listening to her she's
the one who's afraid to take the debate
stage and I consider Laura a debate to
be a job interview the people of Arizona
the voters of Arizona are the hiring
manager and we're showing up to present
our case for what we want to do for
Arizona I'm happy to do it I've cleared
my schedule three times now to do it and
we're going to show up Sunday for the
final chance for Katie to grow a spine
and join me I kind of doubt she's going
to do it though yeah Another Empty chair
there um Carrie it looks like Hobbs was
just involved in some kind of you know
registration Fiasco where 6 000 ballots
that were incorrect were mailed out and
supposedly they're correcting that but
she's a secretary of state and she's
talking about your experience given what
she just oversaw she well everything
I've done in my life whether it was my
first job one of my first jobs as a
janitor all the way up into a journalist
I did and I excelled at and I did with
great work ethic and hard work she's
been incompetent in every role she's
ever played including and most
importantly a secretary of state yes six
thousand ballots the wrong ballot sent
out in our primary election she gave
guidance to how many ballots needed to
go out and in Pinal County one of our
biggest counties one hour into election
day they ran out of Republican only
ballots she's completely incompetent the
Arizona Supreme Court has called her
that in their recent ruling and she's
only showed up for work 19 days out of
the last six months she's had the
Secretary of State's office closed due
to covid oh my God as I'm saying get
your butt back to work Katie you know
nobody gets to show up 19 days in six
months oh my okay first of all you told
me something I didn't know and I love
that one I guess tells me something I
don't so that is that's a that's that is
absolutely a disqualifier right there of
all the things I've heard about her
that's one of the worst
um Carrie now we we heard today of
course that President Trump was
subpoenaed to appear before the January
6 committee after the election you know
they're trying to hold on to relevance
as long as possible your reaction to
that
I'm just amazed at how they're obsessed
with President Trump I get asked about
him every day on the campaign Trail I
think he's fantastic and I'll take any
question that deals with President Trump
and I always start with don't we miss
him and don't we miss his policies and
don't we miss the economy under
President Trump but I'll tell you what
I've been on the campaign Trail Laura
about 500 and I think eight days now
nobody ever asks about what that
commission is up to nobody ever asks
about Ukraine everyone's asking about
our wide open border drugs pouring in
illegal immigration they're asking about
the education system that's brainwashing
our children they're concerned about the
crime that's Rising on the streets and
that's why they're voting Republican
because Republicans and the new
Republican party have the common sense
ideas to the problems that we're facing
the left is pushing nonsense we're
pushing Common Sense what what one thing
will you do first when you get settled
uh into office if you should win this
even before I get settled after I take
the oath of office in the first hour
we're going to issue a declaration of
invasion on our border and we're going
to take back control of our border from
the cartels that Joe Biden has ceded
control to and we are going to secure
the Border stop the fentanyl from
pouring across and the people from being
trafficked across our border and then
we're going to get to work on a whole
bunch of other things including
restoring honesty and faith in our
elections and turning our education
system around we want to start offering
after 10th grade in high school we want
to offer kids the opportunity to get
trade skill training vocational training
and career certification in high school
so our kids are ready for the work to to
be in the workforce out there we've got
lots of jobs we just need the people to
fill them Carrie I can't wait to see how
this all plays out if we don't talk to
you before election night we very well
may talk to you before election night I
think you're going to win this best of
luck out there keep fighting thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else